we now have a situation where there are
certainly millions of people in the
United States at minimum who are furious
with Fox News they wrongly believe
Tucker Carlson's firing was for
political reasons they agree with
Trump's attacks on Fox News which have
been going on now for months you have a
group of people who are looking for any
reason to find something other than Fox
News to now become what they watch
Trump going on CNN
is now giving all of those people the
opportunity to say you know what CNN
maybe is fake news or maybe it was back
when Trump was president but Fox Now is
a disaster I'm abandoning fox fox is now
the enemy and look CNN is at least
giving my guy the time of day they're
going to give him a town hall
[Music]
the timing is is actually quite perfect
for CNN from a business standpoint